thanks for it for being here at
uh just to say again that we warmly
welcome the fact that the negotiations
between the British government and the
European commission have now concluded
and that there is a deal on the table
um we've been meeting today with our
team of mlas
because our preparations are now active
for a return of the assembly and a
return of the executive and we believe
the time is of the essence we know that
we Face very very big challenges uh
economically socially in terms of Public
Service provision and we also know that
there's big opportunities as well for
the north of Ireland and the
opportunities are coming at us coming at
us now we're satisfied that the
agreement struck
um does essential things
it ensures that there will be no
hardening of the border on our Island it
ensures the protection of the Good
Friday agreement of the all-ireland
economy and of course crucially ongoing
access to the European market we of
course have issues and areas where more
clarification Mission will be required
but it is our absolute firm view that
those clarifications can be sought and
gained with an active assembly and with
an executive
um in place
I think that a great tribute should be
paid to the people and to the electorate
who have been incredibly patient and I
think at times incredibly frustrated
with the entire political process people
went to the uh polls last May we're now
what nine months on
um and we need government and we need us
now so the team is here every every
single one of us is aware that we have a
big job of work to do those colleagues
who will be in ministerial office uh in
committees chairing communities members
of committees representing their
constituencies and their communities and
we're very very anxious to get back to
work and none more so than uh Michelle
O'Neill
and we always ensure to order the time
when she will lead the executive as a
first Minister for all
thanks Mary Lou and I think I mean the
only things that I would add to all of
that I mean the negotiation is no
complete and the deal is done and the
illness is an all of us now to be around
that executive table and taken on the
matters of the day the things that are
actually concerning people the people
out there who are waiting on wearing
Master our Health Service workers who
are out on the picket lines are public
sector workers that are out on the
picket lines they need us to be in the
executive and that's where we stand
ready to be what our team stands ready
to be I think that now we find ourselves
on the other end of this negotiation
there is enormous potential for us now a
potential that must be grass this is
about more jobs better jobs this is
about growing our economy and that's
where all of our minds need to be
focused in the time ahead I rarely find
myself agreeing with the British prime
minister you may find it hard to believe
but I do think that the opportunity that
we now have of access to both markets
has to be grabbed under with both hands
and there's no time to waste because
we're about to attend in Washington a
number of events that will be to
celebrate St Patrick's Day but as you
all know that's about encouraging
investment here that's about the
economic potential of here and we have
in quick succession now a daily being
done on the protocol we have now um
we'll go to the states as I said next
week to celebrate St Patrick's Day very
quickly in the aftermath of that comes
the anniversary of the Good Friday
agreement the economic potential for us
here is enormous and this is a moment
not to be missed so over the past 24
hours we spent some time speaking to the
business Community we've spoken to
people out there who are I think given a
very cautious welcome to this deal they
obviously want to make their way through
the detail of which of all of that but
that should not delay the the formation
of an executive that's where we all
should be today that's where we're
focused on and that's the message that
we believe the public at home want to
hear and they want to hear when the
exactly is going to be formed they want
to hear how we're going to tackle
together all of the parties the huge
financial situation that we have ahead
of us and Connor can speak a lot more
about that in terms of the budget
refreshers that we have but all the
executive parties need to be working
together in this time to secure maximum
Advantage for the people that we
represent collectively here and there
should be no more delays in all of that
I've tried to get around everybody folks
so okay
a deal was always available
um what was missing was
good faith negotiations what was missing
really was a pragmatism from the British
government and I think this prime
minister has been absolutely right to
act pragmatically to act with good faith
and to engage with Europe to deliver a
deal that I believe
um covers the basis we do have to work
through some of the detail and we will
all do that but certainly we have now a
viable basis for a return of the
executive and the assembly and that is a
very very good news story not just for
the north of Ireland that's a great news
story for all of the country and uh it
is therefore absolutely imperative that
we don't miss a beat that we use this
momentum now to get government back open
and running and at the end of the day
you know it's the people and the
electorate who are always right and they
have stated through their votes the the
complexion of this family and the
executive that they want and there's an
onus on all of us now each and every one
of us in political life to make sure
that that's delivered
thanks Tracy
um
[Music]
foreign
so Prosperity hurts no one for as far as
he needs to Advantage everyone and the
success of the north the success of the
whole island they're all banged up
together that's the reality and I I
think the business Community is north
and south know this so we want success
for everybody we want it for every
Community we wanted for our business
Community but we also want it for um our
young people for our workers
um to have good jobs good prospects and
a good standard of living and listen
we can only make that happen
When government and politics here works
so this is in everybody's interest this
is a win for everyone the return of the
assembly the return of the executive is
a win for everybody and the truth is
Tracy that
the protections contained in the
protocol were a consequence of brexit I
do not propose to rehash all of that all
over again you'll be very happy to hear
but but the truth is that we do have to
protect the Good Friday agreement we do
have to protect our all- Island economy
and we do have to ensure that access to
to the European market is guaranteed and
that's what was those were the prizes
always what what had been missing was a
viable good faith engagement
unfortunately and you've heard Michelle
O'Neill speak add to Adam with the
British prime minister so this is a
moment for the media to kind of savor
because this this this is uh not
something that happens every day that
that we can see now the opportunity and
I just hope and we hope that that
everybody has the wish
you know the common sense
and the Goodwill to grab the opportunity
now so we're we're not into
um even retrospectively now finger
pointing right that's no there's
absolutely nothing to be gained in that
the deal is done the negotiation is over
Clarity where it's needed can be
achieved with a functioning assembly and
with government and the executive back
up and running that's where we're at
that's why we're meeting today because
we we are getting ready now for for
those things to happen you see the
fundamentals remain because the
fundamental is for us for the protection
of the Good Friday agreement and the oil
Island economy and those things are
still consistent we also equally in the
same vein would have said that we need
to protect what was working and smooth
over what wasn't working and that has
also been achieved so I think that that
is something that certainly the business
Community reflecting to be a good day
out so that's something that the
business Community yesterday we're
reflecting to us that they're now expect
that we would have an executive restored
equally that expect that we should now
maximize the potential and use the
anniversary of the Good Friday agreement
to be a real Catalyst for recant
investment we know this is the
appointment of a special Envoy in Joe
Kennedy he wants to come here and focus
on our economy he wants to bring
maximize our investment here we want
that too but that's a job for all of us
collectively and political leadership to
come together and take this opportunity
and not miss this moment
Stephen
you said it's right that the people you
know look at this deal and take their
time what in your hand is reasonable and
unreasonable when it comes to the
timeline here for example
is it unreasonable to say to the DDP
okay take the next two weeks to look at
this and make a decision by say some
Patrick's Day
would you want to leave okay well I just
I think that we shouldn't Focus now I
think what the public at home are
focusing on a deal has been done and the
dup said that they removed themselves
from this executive in which to
influence negotiations so we're now at
the point of the end of the negotiation
so let's get the executive up and
running everybody will take their time
because there's been a considerable
amount of text legal agreements legal
tax you know uh the command paper all
the different documents have been put
out there we're all working our way
through that but let's do that but
equally let's service the needs of the
people that we represent let's get into
the executive and do that and that
should have been done last May and I
would suggest that today that's exactly
where we should be so there isn't an
endless amount of time here what the
public expect is that we respond to the
fact that a deal has now been done and
the X factors to be in the executive
that's why our team are here today we're
up and at it we're ready we're good to
go do you think it's unreasonable for
the GDP to say look we want two to three
weeks to think about this to go through
this line by line before we can get a
definitive response well look I mean in
some ways even the the timelines are
established for us I mean as Michelle
said
um
the focus will move to Washington for St
Patrick's Day I mean just bear in mind
all of this as it plays out isn't just a
national story this is an international
story and the International Community is
watching now people who have had very
considerable skin in this game and
they're asking the question the deal now
being done
can those in leadership here in Ireland
in the north actually now do what needs
to be done can they lead from the front
and nobody's denying it of course it's
reasonable that people study the
documentation that where there's a need
for clarity and some of that Clarity
will only emerge when we see legislation
so we know that of course we're
reasonable about that but all of that
work can be done whilst there is a
functioning executive and a functioning
assembly so the timeline St Patrick's
Day the 25th anniversary of the Good
Friday again where all eyes will be on
the north of Ireland and the question it
seems to us uh for for people in
politics is what do you want the world
to see do you want to see an up a Vista
of opportunity and positivity uh or not
for us that's where it's at we want
these opportunities for every community
and for all of our people and we hope
that colleagues from other parties are
in that same frame of mind
Rebecca
coming up to the 25th anniversary
weekend Friday agreement on the dep from
also I didn't seem to be taking lunch to
make a decision they're certainly not
going to make it before the local
Assembly Election that means the
atmosphere more toxic memorandum of the
summer period you may not understanding
this year at all quite concerning itself
is it a humiliation
okay let Connor come in well I don't
think anybody would consider that
reasonable at all uh I mean we've
clearly made the point at our position
right through these issues around the
protocol and the negotiations which
finished uh remember last February it
didn't pick up against November was that
that should not prevent an exactly being
basis as a matter of fact there was a
seat at the committee table for the
first Deputy first Minister had they
been in place throughout the course of
the last year but the dep walked away
from that so the idea that this can go
on out of an item to suit electoral
reasons for any party I don't think
would be acceptable to the public at all
this issue has been finished and done we
should never have a broken heart attack
which we should have agreed this time
last year a three-year budget which
would have put a billion pounds of extra
money into the Health Service which
would mean that people currently facing
crisis in their everyday work in the
Health Service wouldn't be in that
position we'd be recruiting more staff
we'd be trying to get people better paid
jobs within the Health Service all of
that could have happened over the course
of the last year while we sat waiting
for negotiation to begin so the idea
that we continue to sit that way when
people are out trying to get a third day
as pay in the public sector when people
are still struggling with the pressures
in the Health Service I don't think
would be acceptable to anyone we need to
get back to work now that's what we were
elected to do
James do you think the duper with some
valuable time I said overall the detail
in the state
well I would encourage the dup to get
around the executive table and let's
take on the things that aren't worrying
people at home right now
um I think that you know we all know
we're living through the overused word
of unprecedented times but it is a
reality that people are struggling with
the cost of living or health services or
health services and crisis we unless are
just completely out of order to be quite
Frank about it and the public expect us
to work together and do our very very
best for them we're dealing with a
budget that we haven't been able to set
we're dealing with a budget that is you
know has a characteristics of over 12
years of Tory austerity which has led to
our Health Service building crisis we've
been big work to do here and the parties
have to come together we need to stand
together in terms of taking this on
directly with the British treasury
because the finances here are just
completely out of control so we have a
huge huge amount of work to do and I
think that it's you know for the
ordinary person sitting at home today
perhaps watching this press or watching
the event of the past couple of days
they want to know when is the executive
going to be up and running
um and that's what I would just instead
of I would take more of an approach of
encourage the dep as
with the rest of us and let's do what we
need to do for the public that we
represent and in the end you know to to
address all of the challenges that
Michelle has set out we're going to need
a united front that's the reality if we
are all agreed that there's a crisis in
in that in the Health Service with
waiting lists well then you need
everybody in the executive every party
to the executive to be absolutely
determined that we meet that challenge
but for any of that to happen we need
government back so all everybody who
enjoys a democratic mandate has to now
exercise it in good faith in Goodwill
and actually collectively
um so we're hopeful that uh Good Sense
will prevail
aren't we Michelle we are indeed
um Anya and then seanana come to you
next
uh
well
[Music]
heart
Augustine Realtors
okay and Shawnee
we're ready to be in the executive today
we're already to be there today we're
ready last May when we had an election
that the public voted for to make
politics working for the parties to work
together there isn't any alternative
um here car Sharon is the name of the
day it's where we all he debates the
nature in which politics works here so I
think it would be a hugely missed
opportunity for the dep not to come
around that executive table and Avail of
the opportunity that we now have in
front of us as we sit here today the
international stage is watching as they
know that we have access to both markets
and and what we can do with that is just
enormous and I think that as we enter
into the GFA anniversary all of our
energy all of our efforts have to be
faced in the one way and that is to try
and batter people's lives here
ultimately that's what politics is about
so I just don't think that that's
somewhere where I'm going to go right
now today the illnesses we would say
that anybody with um who's been talented
with the responsibility of being a
political leadership needs to come
together and actually make this work
um
Amanda sorry Amanda
Michelle do you think that you you're
ashamed of being in the first limited
position and then the next Community
he's considering its position about
re-entering government and John you
mentioned the other night that the storm
of Great American happened to you at
first glance look like a mechanism of
Last Resort and obviously Champion
haven't gone through every single line
but uh what specific areas have should
have been concerned about for example
being share some of the alliance
concerns around depression of concern
and around the break
well unfortunately I mean the dup have
offered up the pre-tax of the protocol
as the reason as to why they're not
around the executive ever the deal's
done the negotiation has been had
so there is no rationale for to not be
in the executive so that's why we repeat
our message again today to the dup to
join with the rest of the parties the
onus is on them you are the the single
party that are blocking the formation of
an executive to come around the
executive table and that needs to be
done now there shouldn't be any more
delays do you think it's in the mix so
the first Minister issue well I think
that we should
move through the next couple of days
um giving people the space so much to
make their mind up on this day but the
reality is that back in May the people
spoke and they did return me um the
first Minister designated that I am in
this position I am ready to form an
executive I am ready to work with others
and the dep need to join with us in
order to make that work so
um there's no reason around I believe
for the dep to stay out of the executive
right now they need to be in the
executive if the protocol and the
negotiation are in the protocol is in
fact the reason as to why they're not
around that executive team
it it strikes me with the protocol that
it was always a document that had the
capacity to identify and diagnose
problems as their rooms I mean that's
the market a little bit the protocol
represented sorts of fundamental and
dramatic trade and shift and that was
introduced practically overnight in the
month of sort of December January 2019.
so it always had that ability and I
think its language was very much about
problem resolution uh and I I think when
you struck me reading the the language
around the storm and break that it is
very much a mechanism of Masters or
because it talks about all of the steps
that Khan should be taken before
anything such as a brief being applied
would ever come into force it talks
about dialogue who talks about
identifying problems it talks about the
mechanisms in which that can be raised
the reason why more clarity is needed is
because like any
um sort of complicated legal text there
may well be enabling legislation there
will naturally be questions that arise
that's natural I mean I would say that
that's responsible that that card is
sought but as I say it does strike me
that the language around that I think
reinforces the language of the protocol
which is resolution to problems as they
arise making life easier for our
businesses bring in prosperity to this
jurisdiction and that's why it strikes
me and it continues to strike me albeit
we need further Clarity that it is
something that that if it ever was to be
used it would be a last resort
mechanisms
no I mean again anything that requires
clarification I mean that's you haven't
quite asked this but I'm answering this
way anything that requires clarification
is something that can run parallel to
the main focus and that is a restored
assembly a restored executive to deal
with all of the issues that have been
outlined already today
thanks John Jacob sorry I never thought
about you
thanks very much
um
is
to insurance
of both communities is
it you know the honest if you've been
saying that for a moment since 10 months
however long distance May that is
clearly you know they have
technology whatever
um
thanks well look just just in terms of
the the reform piece
um I mean we've said all along that
we're open to conversations of course
about making politics work and making it
work better and in fact there's a
subcommittee so I've been executive
assembian executive Review Committee
that sits under an ofmdfm that actually
has the the job and the work of
considering all of that so of course I
mean we're 25 years in things evolve
things change we're always going to be
open to having those kind of
conversations but we will always be
mindful of not disrupting the very
carefully constructed balances within
the Good Friday
arrangements so so that means parity of
esteem equality recognition for
minorities all of these things need to
be to be weighed and considered to be
honest with you perhaps the biggest
reform that we need now in this in this
moment is a bit of reformed thinking
among some I mean the idea for example
that endlessly you can Meander along in
a state of Lendl is not politically real
the world doesn't work like that so
there has to be if if I could have a
wish if I had a magic wand but sadly I
don't have but if I did and could wish
for one thing I would wish for that
level of realism to Dawn because you
have whole Generations
of people who are relying on people like
us you know elected people in this room
and Beyond to actually do the right
things make the Right Moves and seize
all of those opportunities that Michelle
and Carter have spoken about and that's
what politics is about that's what Brad
and Bossier politics is about but on on
the issue discussing reform of course
we've been we have been open to that we
remain open to that
whilst maintaining a commitment to the
essential balances within the Good
Friday because they're all there for a
reason born of of bad history so we
don't want any of that bad history to
ever repeat itself and your second
question just to finish on a probably on
on a good point here the next recall of
the assembly should be the one that
actually elects a first and Deputy first
Minister Alex
um our ministers to go into their
departments and do their job and as a
family members back in that chamber
every day debating policy that's the
next recall that we should have the
public deserve no less and that's what
we're ready for that's why we're here
again today to work with our team to be
an Upstate at Readiness so thank you
folks thank you